hey friends
how's it going thank you for uh spending
some time with us today appreciate it
this is uh only the second talk that i
have given in person in two years so if
i mess it up that's why i'm a little bit
nervous i'm also not used to having
everyone standing
uh so i guess it's probably not
appropriate i don't know if you can sit
on the floor but don't don't feel like
if you're uncomfortable we've got chairs
in the backs uh so you're all kind of
like standing and staring at me which is
a little bit unusual for for a talk
um so i wanted to put together something
that was a little key notey they say
that keynotes are supposed to be about
big thinking about getting people to
change their perspective on stuff and
one of the things that i've been
thinking about during the pandemic is
remote work uh how to make people
successful when i don't get to interact
with them in person i've got people that
i've hired to work with me at microsoft
who have never i've never seen them
i don't know how tall they are
they're about about this big
uh in little squares uh they're always
either way taller or way shorter than i
would have expected when i do meet them
we've got some people who have been
hired and have never been in an office
before
so people come to me with questions
about remote work about what it's like
to work remotely and we talk about that
and i'm also starting to realize now
that i've been in tech this is my 30th
year
coding for money so i'm officially an
old programmer i think i get to say that
now
and i'm thinking about what does that
mean as i head towards the last few
years of my career what does that mean
for folks that are just getting started
so if there's folks here with less than
than 10 years in the business
you use your babies i love you
what does it mean to grow the next
generation of developer uh and uh i'm
going to talk about that today we're
talking about mentorship sponsorship and
systems thinking and how it's enabled me
to to work with a number of new
developers
right off the bat i was told my slides
were unprofessional because i used comic
sans as a font the ndc folks have a very
high standard i came with this they were
immediately disappointed so i came up
with a better
better font
that was a little bit more attractive
looks like my slides are not moving this
is the first thing looks like this runs
java so i can't
can't rely on that there we go
should have got a net clicker so there's
a professional font much nicer and then
i put some uh some title there
but then i was told that the young
people prefer evocative stock
photography you have to have a
photograph that shows how fancy your
office is
so i put together one of those so that's
my office
that's what everyone's office looks like
really it's very typical programmer's
office wouldn't you say with a the sun
streaming in on a sunday afternoon
no clutter of any kind on the desk it's
a very typical programmer office
this is uh actually what a programmer's
office looks like
that's uh more typical
actually that's what an old programmer's
office looks like
so i joke about this a little bit and i
talk about how well that's what a real
programmer's desk looks like and no
that's what a real programmer's desk
looks like the problem with that
sentence isn't those two desks it's real
programmer right a real programmer's
desk looks like your desk it looks like
whatever it should look like it looks
like whatever space you're building for
yourself that makes you happy
i've seen people we've all seen people
where we go to their desk and we go how
do you work like you look at their icons
on their desktop and you're like oh what
are you doing what is what whatever
you're doing it's wrong
but if it's working for them then it
must be explicitly right
so we're changing our perspectives about
what a real programmer looks like some
of them look like this and some of them
look like this and that's okay what we
want to do whether it be at ndc or
anywhere is we want people to feel
welcome we want people to feel like they
can do their best work
now
of course the pandemic happened
and right off the bat we started to see
hustle culture you familiar with that
term hustle that means that you're not
successful because you're not working
hard enough you gotta hustle you gotta
hustle more right you've gotta want it
man
right this is not the ndc way this is
not the way is it we don't like these
kind of people just do it danny do it
work harder
no
do you have a good system does it work
for you awesome that's great it makes me
happy one of the things people told me
during the pandemic is they said well
you're working from home you've got all
this spare time you know if you didn't
learn chinese during the pandemic what
are you doing with all with all the free
time right if you didn't learn f sharp
and the cloud during all your free time
as far as i'm concerned if you survive
the pandemic and you still have a job at
the end you're doing a great job and i
appreciate you
so folks would come to me
and they'd say i need to work harder to
get better at work you know i'm a new
programmer i need to put in 60 hours a
week 80 hours a week this is hustle
culture
and while it's good to work hard well
it's good to hustle it's good to be
passionate it's good to get up in the
morning excited it's not okay for us to
tell our early in career developers the
reason you're not successful is because
you're not doing 80 hours a week
hustle culture is not
not healthy you don't do 30 years
in the software industry with the
philosophy of wake up kick ass and
repeat
you've got to find balance
this is a marathon not a sprint i think
all of us have been burned out at some
time i've never felt what burnout really
feels like yeah
and burnout you know how burnout starts
is you do your you do your nine to five
or your nine to six or your seven to
seven and you go home and you see your
partner and you see your kids and you go
you know i'm a little behind at work i'm
just gonna work late to catch up
and the next thing you know it's 2 a.m
and then it's 7 a.m and then you did it
again
and you keep doing that repeat because
you think i'll just catch up it's a busy
time you know we're in that kind of
april may
june july kind of that's a busy time at
work june july august september kind of
october november december january march
kind of that it's a busy time
at the work and we'll hustle in order to
make that time and then we realize that
that's become our lifestyle that's
really unhealthy and then we don't like
ourselves we don't like our jobs we
don't like our careers and then we do it
to the new generation
we inflict it upon the next gen because
we put in our work
i did hustle i did crunch time so then
you have to do it too so that you can
you can suffer
i don't mean to do it like that but we
do do that don't we
well i um
my son is 16 and he's learning how to
drive a car
so when i learned to drive a car i was
very excited i was like i'm going to
drive this wonderful car that my dad my
dad has and my dad says
before you get to drive the car i need
you to change your own oil
change a tire
rebuild an engine
right because his dad taught him how to
do that and that's how real driver is
right
you know you want to learn to drive a
car you want to go to the school dance
that's great let's talk about the theory
of the internal combustion engine
you want to learn c sharp before we
learn c sharp let's talk about assembler
because you don't deserve a memory
manager garbage collector you're garbage
right that's that's not how we want to
do things
like think about it computers there's a
famous quote that says computers are
where we took a rock we put lightning in
a rock and we made it think
so you don't get to use a computer until
you too have taken two sticks and rubbed
them together and made fire and then
we'll get you the computer
so as an as an elder programmer
i have discovered that one of my biases
one of my biases the things that i'm
internally biased against
is is young people
they're the worst
don't trust anybody under 30. they don't
know what they're doing
some people may be biased against people
of different cultures or people of
different
races i realize that my bias my my
internal reaction is young people they
don't know what they're talking about
but then i realized that that's not
right that's not healthy
the only difference between me
and a young programmer is that i'm old
i'm still here
so then i realize that i need to make
space for those young programmers so
that they become old programmers that's
my job so i catch that bias internally
and i catch those moments where i want
them to drive stick shift
before they drive automatic because i
think that's right so i'm starting to
reevaluate those biases and it's really
made a big difference in my
life so when when quarantine happened
everyone called me and said hey scott
you've been a remote worker at microsoft
for 15 years tell me what it's like to
be a remote worker and i realized that
well working in quarantine sucks you're
in jail but working remotely is a joy
you can go to starbucks or a cafe you
can sit in the corner and work so i
don't know what it's like to work during
a quarantine or a pandemic so i didn't
have a lot of good tips but i did tell
them that you don't want to overwork
that is the thing we've all found as we
have worked remotely and some of us have
gone back to the office we found that
that commute that our commute
ended up just being work so now we're
working an extra hour in the morning and
an extra hour at night and nobody
noticed it
and that's not healthy
so i watch i want people to watch what's
going on in their own bodies and their
own brains
so i'm going to talk today about
intentionality
and deliberate thinking doing things
because you decided to do a thing
as opposed to just letting things happen
by default
one of the things that i'm seeing a lot
of is is doom scrolling do you guys know
what doom scrolling is i'm really not
enjoying this clicker there we go
doom scrolling
is scrolling on social media
for really awful sad things about how
the world is ending and everything sucks
and then when you find something you
confirms your belief that the world
sucks and then you look for more stuff
turns out that scrolling for doom is not
healthy
so i started realizing
that
i would be on the toilet
looking for reasons the world was ending
and there's just something about poo
and the world ending that just makes you
sit sadly in the bathroom
and uh i don't know if it's the sitting
and the pooping part but it's just
really not good healthy behavior
you didn't think you were going to go to
an nbc keynote and learn about my poop
but now you're here and that's what we
have
the reason that i'm saying this
is because we don't talk about this
stuff
you all are doing this
but you don't tell your partners or your
friends you're sad you think it sucks
and you think it's going to get better
if you go into twitter and you pull to
refresh and you find some new bit of
information so i'm being much more
intentional i'm being much more
deliberate about what i'm putting into
myself
i'm intentional about my work i'm
intentional about how i'm dealing with
young people i'm intentionable
intentional on how i'm consuming media
and i'm trying to be more present i'm
trying to be more present and in my
space
i mentioned before that i've been coding
now and this is now in 2022 so it's been
30 years
i could use that 30 years as a as a
cudgel
hey you have an idea about some coding
bonk i've been doing this 30 years
that's not healthy but here's the other
thing have i really been doing it 30
years
i was kind of asleep for seven of that
now i'm not saying like i was you know
in the club like i don't even remember
the 90s man not that kind of forgetting
just kind of like doing your job and not
really thinking about it not being
present and in the moment so there's
years of my experience that didn't
really count
about seven of them i count a couple of
years in the 90s couple of years in the
early 2000s where i wasn't really
thinking
so when the pandemic happened and i not
only was working remotely but i was
stuck working remotely i started getting
deliberate and intentional and i started
building a nest
nesting is super important
a lot of you didn't sign up to work
remotely did you you just had to work
remotely so then you're on your kitchen
counter or you're in your spare bedroom
or you're in your on your back porch
somewhere you found a space
did you intentionally sit down and build
a place for yourself
or did a place just happen by default
for most people it just happened
we have a lady at work who is inside her
pantry the little room that you keep
your like beans and rice in she just
made a space
is that in my head or is that here
i thought i was having a stroke there
brother yeah
i was like it's happening
i'm okay
um
so i made a nest i have a spare bedroom
i'm very blessed to have a little extra
bedroom so i made a space i put pictures
in that space that feed my spirit i put
my monitors the way that i wanted
i don't have a lot of money but i wanted
a million dollar room
it turns out with paint
and ikea you can have a million dollar
room for 300 bucks
so i got some i got some billy shelves
for my my my stuff and my pictures
i got a standing desk and i found a nice
chair
on on craigslist i got a used chair and
i i nested and i was intentional about
it when i say intentional i realized
when i thought about myself that i was
moving from one bedroom
to another bedroom
and that didn't give me enough space
between work and home
so i painted the room a deep chocolate
brown like a library
i put shelves in the room and window
coverings in the room that looked
nothing like the rest of the house
this room doesn't match our decor
according to my wife
uh so it looks completely different and
that's on purpose
and then i commute
some of you commute by rolling out of
bed
and it's the second roll and now you're
at work
right right if you can reach your phone
like that that is too close to work i
would encourage you to put work farther
away so i actually commute
i get out of the house
i walk around the block and then i come
around and i turn back and i go into
another door
that's stupid right well it works for me
that's the thing i knew that something
wasn't working i explored it i thought
about it and i decided a new way would
work and i came up with a new way
so i'm encouraging people that are early
in career i have some people who came
directly out of college
and now they're in a little one bedroom
apartment in seattle somewhere working
for microsoft they've never met anyone
from work they've never been to the
the uh the campus
and those folks
are not being intentional about their
space so they roll out of their bed and
they put their laptop on their kitchen
counter and they work
and it's sad and it's starting to tear
them down so first thing i would do is
encourage you all to make a nest
then
ask yourself is this the time to create
is the time that i'm set up for myself
the right time to make stuff i think
this is falling off i'm not sure what's
happening here
sorry about that can i get my friend to
help me
is this fallen or am i is my head
changing shape in real time
thanks boss
thank you sir appreciate that
so
is the time that you're choosing to
create the right time
are you most productive in the afternoon
are you most productive in the morning
find those times and set them up for
yourself we're all sick of meetings
we're all tired of these things apply
intentionality to when you're going to
create
and then a lot of them early in career
people have been asking me well i don't
really feel like making anything i'm
overwhelmed i'm not really good at
anything
everyone is an expert at something and
you're especially an expert in your own
journey and your own experience
so as i'm trying to explore my biases
towards young people i'm realizing that
a lot of these young people are experts
at stuff that i don't know about right
when i went to school in the 90s
kubernetes didn't exist
so you know i'm an expert on it only if
i work in a production system you can't
become an expert on something just by
reading about it so i'm learning a lot
from these things and i'm encouraging
young people and early and career people
to think about what are the things that
they're an expert at and having them
write about it
i'm also hearing a lot of people talk
about inclusion and wanting more people
to feel comfortable in tech and i've
seen old programmers like myself have a
little bit of an unwelcoming attitude
and it made me realize that we didn't
always have this this is a magazine an
actual physical magazine back when we
had those from 1984 where this young
lady is programming on a ti-99
she's got her bubble gum
and her pigtails and that was what i
grew up and that's what i thought tech
was like it was just nerds doing awesome
stuff and i want people to to feel like
that when they enter the space
but
there's this thing called the technology
priesthood
and this is no disrespect this is just a
religious uh analogy there was a time a
thousand years ago
when
regular people didn't read
right only the priests would read
the regular people would ask the priests
for information and the priest would be
like well let me let me look that up but
don't look at it just let me see and
then they would and they would go okay
well it says here and then they would
tell them so the relationship between
information and the people who wanted
information was not balanced
this quote here is knowledge is power
and it tends to be hoarded experts in a
field rarely want people to understand
what they do that sounds like something
you would say in on on twitter in 2022.
that's actually a quote from a computer
magazine from 1974.
so people were noticing this this
this technology priesthood this this um
gatekeeping
standing at the gate and saying no you
can't come in
have you ever gone to your family
holiday events
and you see your cousins and your
grandmother and your aunties and uncles
and you know that the responsibility of
the computer person at the family event
is to set up their printer to run
windows update right i mean you know
right okay
have you ever met like a cousin you
haven't seen in a while and the
conversation is like how's it doing what
are you what are you oh you're a
computer person oh
i'm not a computer person i don't know
anything about computers and then you
kind of fade away we've created this
environment by which there are computer
people
and then everyone else
right where being able to go file save
as that's a thing you put on your
linkedin like you know do you know
office i do know office do you know how
to go save as
less so
right i'm an office worker but i don't
really know where my files are right
so do you know where your files are
young people they don't even know that
the file system is a thing my kid's 16
no idea where the files are they're in
google drive or they're in one drive but
otherwise if they were on c colon temp
you're never going to see that file
again it's over
so
what have we done as computer people to
to take a relationship that should be
like this and we made it like this we
made them feel bad
my non-technical parent calls me and
says i don't know what i did to the
computer
i think i broke it the relationship with
the system is broken
so i'm trying to get people to think
about that
it could be a system at work and you're
talking to a new programmer who's only
been in the business for a couple of
years i think i broke it i think i broke
production
i think i dropped a table in production
and then we make them feel bad about
that rather than thinking about
how do we have systems that would allow
someone who just got here to break
production
it's not their fault it's the system's
fault you got to think about those
things i talk about this term
gatekeeping
gatekeeping are these are the decision
makers that sit in a place and control
information flow so as someone at
microsoft's who's kind of a
middle to upper manager like me
i can gatekeep if i choose to if i want
to teach someone c sharp and i say you
have to learn c first and then you have
to learn c plus and then you get c sharp
i don't make the rules well actually i
do exactly make the rules
right we always hear that phrase i don't
make the rules
turns out you do
you can change the rules
i was teaching
classes on c sharp and computer science
from the metal
up
let's learn about assembler let's learn
about c let's learn about memory
management okay now we don't need memory
management i was teaching it about
history
but the kids the younger people are
learning from the glass of their monitor
back not the metal up the glass back
they load up they hit f12 tools in
chrome or edge and they go look that's
javascript
that's the source code for the internet
it's not for me to say well actually i
just let it go they just don't need to
know that stuff
so if we bring it back to my son who's
trying to learn how to drive
does he need to know stick shift now we
get into a real conversation about what
gatekeeping means
here's where i struggle as a person of a
certain age
if you drive a car and you know how to
drive manual
you have a different relationship with
the car
i would argue you are a better driver
you know more about how it works and if
it has a problem you're gonna be able to
get through it
that said
what if he just wants to ride in an uber
platform as a service
let's say that the car has a flat tire
he gets in another uber
i assume that the other uber is garbage
collected i don't know what happens i
don't know that guy right that guy good
luck uber guy
but
if he doesn't understand that that the
tire can break and the uber driver has
to fix that tire then does he even know
the uber driver exists
does he have empathy for the existence
of that driver wouldn't it be nice if he
had the power to get out of the car and
help the person with the
with the tire so then the question is
how far down should he go
should he rebuild the engine with the
gentleman
should he fix that person's oil i didn't
say you need to be a mechanic i do think
you should take the level that you
operate at
and go one level below
if you drive automatic
learn stick shift do it once or twice so
it's in your it's in your brain
you don't have to do it professionally i
didn't ask you to be a race car driver
but you don't get to go from uber rider
to f1 racer
without understanding the stack
so we need to think about those things
when someone is going to be doing their
job what do they need to know to be
really effective at their jobs so while
i'm going to let my son drive an
automatic i am going to have him drive
manual a couple of times so that he can
get out of trouble if he needs to he's
just going to go one level down the call
stack than where he's used to
so if you can do that then you can start
sharing your experience about what
you've learned and you can put out good
work and you can tell people about it so
the other thing that i've been telling
people to do is not to waste their
keystrokes
this is a thing that happens at work
where people are writing really long
emails during the pandemic
if your email scrolls i'm not going to
read your email
an email is where
keystrokes go to die
right let's say after this talk one of
you lovely people sends me a note and
says hey great talk scott i have a
question
i never thought of that question
that question's a gift what a great
question danny thank you so much for
that question but you know
danny and i are friendly but i'm not
going to give danny 5 000 of my
keystrokes for free
i don't know you like that right because
i want to go and write seven paragraphs
and danny's gonna be like thanks
all right so that was great thank you
for that gift i just wasted an hour
typing and uh and now you know paypal me
i guess
what should i do
i should put those keystrokes in a blog
post or a wiki or literally anywhere
with a url send the url to my friend and
then go to sleep
and then those keystrokes will live
while i am sleeping
true story conserve your keystrokes
you have a finite number of keystrokes
left in your hands before you die
yeah little morbid people that laughter
right there that was the laughter of
pain because that was what that was that
was the like
i made a website for you painful
laughter guy
keysleft.com
i can't see
because i'm old
keys left dot com
how many keys do you have left
let's say that laughter guy is 29 a
crisp 29 he types 80 words a minute
he has 281 million keystrokes left and
it's going down right now because he's
not typing
okay this is assuming you're going to
live to be 90 and you're going to be a
salary person your whole life but you
have
93 novels left in your hands why aren't
you writing novels man
you've got uh
28 000 love letters
do better
or
a million and a half emails to your boss
right where do you want your time to go
this is that intentionality that we were
talking about i want people to be
thinking about intentionality and what
you're doing with your time and why
you're spending your time doing the
things you're going to do so one of the
ways that i'm becoming a better mentor
and a better manager at work is i'm
writing less emails and i'm writing more
documents
i'm writing less emails and i'm putting
content in places where i can have
a url i'm going to have a new employee
start soon i'm not going to write the
same email that i write every time a new
employee i'm going to use an existing
one i'm going to save my keystrokes this
is helping people do better at work
because writing things down culture
supports people in other time zones you
write the document and you go to sleep
the document gets forwarded around it
gets talked about everybody wins
so that's an important tip
and then again i come back to that point
where people feel like they are
and i really don't like this clicker
come on clicker people feel like maybe
they're not expert enough at something
we are all amateurs i said i've been
doing this for 30 years everything i
learned in school except for c
is dead
every single thing that i learned in
school is gone none of these things
exist anymore
no one's writing stuff in dos in object
pascal
which is what i learned in 1991
right very few people are writing x86
assembler right now most people are
doing text boxes over data so it's
caused me to re-evaluate that experience
i said that about seven years of my
experience are repeated
do you have 20 years experience or do
you have the same year 20 times
we know these people at work they don't
come to ndc so we can talk about them
because they're not here
you know this person i've been here 20
years young person respect my experience
you've literally had the same job doing
the exact same thing for 20 years it is
the same year 20 times
now that doesn't mean you have to switch
jobs it means you have to wake up
you just go huh is this a process that
can be improved is this a system that i
can change is there an interaction with
how i deal with people that i can modify
and in doing that it keeps things fresh
and it keeps you in the business longer
this gentleman here is tim berners-lee
he invented the world wide web
lovely gentleman one of the things that
i love about him is that he has a title
down here that is very modest
all the young people want to be senior
engineers
you want to be a senior web developer
you can be a senior web developer when
berners-lee puts senior in front of his
name
but until that happens we're all just
web developers
if if i were berners-lee i would just
put the
right that's a flex that is a flex yeah
you're a senior developer i'm the
web developer
i love that because he's very modest he
understands that there's things that he
doesn't know and i appreciate that
so i'm not too
old to get a mentor i want to get a
mentor i want someone who can teach me
their perspective on systems just
because i was there when the internet
was built doesn't mean that i know
everything about it there's new thinking
in distributed systems and kubernetes in
platform as a service in the cloud the
cloud didn't exist when i got a degree
understanding those kinds of things i
can get benefits from a younger person
and a younger person can go and be a
mentor
so if you're thinking about mentorship
and sponsorship i would encourage you to
not only find someone to mentor you
even though you are later in your career
but i would encourage you to find uh a
mentee that is possibly of a different
age
that has been really really inspiring
for me a lot of young people don't
expect
an old head like me to ask them for
their advice but they light up when they
do
i i was not a good mentor for a while
i use these this these hand gestures to
indicate the power relationship between
people like when you're talking to your
boss yeah this is my boss i'm so sorry
boss right you want to talk to people
like peers
when i was a mentor i i made the
mentorship relationship
a weekly lecture from an old dude
i didn't mean to
but i'm an old dude and i have all this
information so you should listen to me
so every week i'll mentor you by being
an old dude
at
scale and that's not cool
in fact i needed to change that
relationship and be more intentional
about it and think about what it is a
mentor is supposed to do
a mentor is supposed to help someone
else define their dream think about
their strengths give them advice and
guide them
not lecture
that's what parents do
i didn't want to be someone else's
secondary parent
then i realized
that there's a fundamental difference
between mentorship
which can be a finite amount of time it
can be for different reasons and
sponsorship which is giving
opportunities to people that they
wouldn't ordinarily
have sometimes we hear this term luck
thrown around a lot say i'm very lucky
and then other people don't like that
and they kind of they bristle at that
term luck i worked hard for everything i
did there was no luck involved
the problem is the answer is both
luck
is opportunity
plus being prepared
you worked hard you were prepared
opportunities happened though and you
were ready for them
if you were super prepared
and no opportunity presented itself
you'd be like i'm so unlucky and
everything is bad i'm going to work
harder and be more prepared
but if the opportunities don't arrive
there's nothing you can do about it
so when we acknowledge things like
privilege sometimes people don't like
that word we acknowledge luck
we realize that
yeah sure you worked hard no one's
saying you didn't work hard
but you were also very fortunate to have
opportunities presented to you
when i was 12
my grade 5 teacher
let me take the computer home
okay this is the 80s we didn't have a
computer per classroom every kid didn't
have a chromebook
there was a computer
not for the class for the school there
was an apple too this was a poor school
she let me sneak it out of the building
on friday nights
my dad would back the pickup truck up
against the school and we would squirrel
the computer into the back of the thing
through a window and we would steal it
off into the night
and i would have it back
by sunday
so that no one knew it was gone
this is a teacher enabling me why me
i don't know where the other kids in the
neighborhood are i don't know who else
no one else had that opportunity there
was only the one computer
what was it that she saw in me to allow
me to do that what a gift that was
there's some
parallel universe that's split in half
with some loki variant version of me
that's probably in jail for fake ids and
white-collar crime
that didn't get that computer because
that fifth grade teacher mrs hill
saw something in me i was ready
and the opportunity arise but she
created luck
for me she made luck
and for me to forget that almost 40
years later
would disrespect all the work that she'd
done she was not just a mentor she was a
sponsor
so
we hear about privilege
being a man and being this and being
that one of the things we don't talk
about much is what's called level
privilege
if you're a vp at your company
that's powerful you're much more
powerful than the junior engineer
do you know that when i email like
junior engineers at work i don't really
think about my spelling
but when i email my vp
i check the spelling
she is going to get a clean crispy mail
with indentation and bullet points and
maybe a little emoji or two just to be
professional
does you think she knows that i'm doing
that you know you're doing that you know
you're careful when you email your boss
and that's totally different than you
email the intern
that's level privilege
the thing that's fun about level
privilege you have unlimited level
privilege i will not run out
so if a new engineer comes to the
company
what does it cost me to say
i'm just going to use you as an example
denny because you're standing right here
i'm like hey
danny uh you know that was actually
denny's work let's uh let's have him
present to the the all hands that'd be
great oh yeah you know and juan had some
thinking about that why don't you go
ahead and tell the group what that was
about
one moment
i have unlimited number of those that
means i don't do that once a week and
then go haha i'm such a good i'm an ally
for the people yes pet pet pat no do it
all day
you can do warm introductions people
don't realize that the good old boys
network and tech it's just warm
introductions oh you're friends with
them and i'm friends with them so then
we must be friends
a to b b to c a to c okay cool well
we're cool and he knows you you must be
cool i'll introduce you to this job
the warm introduction is how we create
luck for people
that didn't exist now they have to work
hard nobody's getting jobs for just
hanging out and being pretty they have
to do the work
right
but they have to be ready and then the
opportunity presents itself so what i'm
trying to do and encourage us to do is
to think about
how can we put a spotlight on someone
how can we create luck
they may never know this is important
they may never know you created that
luck
and it's important that you not tell
them
you remember 10 years ago when i had you
present in front of the vice president
that was that was me
that wasn't you just want to let you
know just to minimize all that hard work
that you put in
no you don't do that that's called
transactional networking
you don't want to network with people
and then keep track and keep score
but what i love doing i love doing is
i'll come to a conference like this and
afterwards someone will say
14 years ago you retweeted something of
mine and it made me have the confidence
to quit my job and i started this little
business
does that mean that i created their
little business and i did all the hard
work no i just gave them a spotlight
and i forgot about it
and that was the moment that was there
mrs hill gave you a computer moment
do that more friends
don't go a week without introducing
someone to someone you know without
giving a young person at work a chance
to give a presentation in front of the
team
they might not succeed then wait a
little while and give them a spotlight
later
there's a whole spectrum of sponsorship
you can strategize you can connect
people you can give opportunities you
can advocate what is an
advocate that's someone who's talking
nice about you when you're not in the
room
costs you nothing what a joy
once you get addicted to this you're
going to have so much fun
telling people about all the great early
and career folks
that you're going to lift up and give
opportunities to it's so cool now
sometimes when people start mentoring
they're worried that um they got to do
it forever
like it's a relationship or a marriage
you do not have to mentor them forever
you can break up with your mentor
what you do is you set up phases
reasons that you're doing your
mentorship
we're gonna focus on getting you to the
next level getting you that big
promotion getting you the transfer to
the other project that's that's the the
boundaries of this mentorship
relationship what's your career phase
and what's theirs
the person that you're mentoring should
not be in your direct reports
because it changes the power dynamic
and they shouldn't be someone who has
power over you if you're being mentored
they should be diagonal to you
in the business
i use that example of a time-shifted
version
of yourself you know when you see
someone you say you remind me of me
that's cool you're probably meeting
another variant of yourself that's time
shifted that's perfect they're diagonal
to you they're they're you that took a
different road you can guide them and
make them successful and make them the
best version of themselves
and then again make it a two-way street
not a regular scheduled lecture with an
old person
so one of the things that i think is the
most fun about being old in tech is
having a lot of stories so as we get
towards the end here and we're all
standing and we're kind of getting a
vibe and feeling about what we're going
to see next here at ndc and all the
great talks that we're going to have i
want to share a couple of fun stories
about things in tech
and this is what's great i want the
young people to collect their own
stories so that they can tell them as
well so i'm going to share a couple of
mine and these are the things that i
talk about with my mentees
first thing is that they ask me
what should i specialize in
what what technology should i pick
i don't freaking know i mean what do i
know like
am i going to go kubernetes
that's the thing right probably not web3
whatever it is but the thing that you're
the thing that you want to do i don't
know you want to be a t-shaped developer
you ever heard that term t shape you
know the shape of the letter t you want
to be broad
understand systems computers have cpu
and memory and networking and storage
and then the t goes deep in one thing
i don't care if that one thing is rust
or go or c sharp or whatever
that top part of the t has to be broad
the analogy i use is the swiss army
knife that's the that's why the swiss
army is the power they are today
the swiss army knife this is a great
little knife my dad gave me a swiss army
knife when i was 12. this knife is
useless there's nothing here there's a i
mean i think this is a wine cork of some
kind i've never used that
it's got tiny scissors it's got a tiny
pliers but it's a pretty good knife
it's kind of t-shaped it's got a bunch
of things that it's kind of okay at and
then it goes deep in the knife there's
like three knives
that's the way i want to be as a
developer
i don't want to be a specialized tool
because what if that thing goes away i
can take any one of those tools and
improve it and make it better and go
deeper on it
so if c sharp dies or if kubernetes
isn't the next thing
the fund of freaking metals are still
there so it's okay to be a funny little
knife that's not amazing at everything
you just want to be at least a good
knife
i see a lot of exciting people coming
into tech and they're focused on a
technology i'm going to learn javascript
but then they don't know how to drive
stick shift
they don't know about how javascript
fits into the ecosystem they don't have
systems
thinking they just learned how to write
a for loop in javascript and that can be
really challenging
so i talk about these things when i meet
with my mentees
and my sponsored folks there's problem
solving in tech there's layering there's
composing systems and there's patterns
let's start with problem solving problem
solving
is asking yes no questions at scale this
is the difference between an early and
career and a later and career individual
is you know how you get stuck on a
problem
you go find some senior programmer and
you've been thinking about this for
hours
and they go
is it dns and you go ah crap yeah it's
dns how did you do that i've been
thinking about this for days and you
went and you said it's that and then you
go
the real answer is i'm old i've seen a
lot it's always dns right
problem solving at scale okay asking yes
no questions so i went and gave this
talk
at uh at a young girls coding seminar
and i'm sure they were thrilled to see
me right because they love the old old
guys on tick tock hey kids hey fellow
kids so i show up and i said we're going
to learn how to code yay
and i wanted to do something different
because this is a bunch of young young
high school kids i think they were 14 15
year old girls and i said all right
my toaster is broken
and then i made it real awkward and
cringe and just let it sit there i
thought we were going to learn how to
code
well yeah but i need toast
can we fix can we fix the toaster
what do you think i should do
and one of the kids is like well you
should probably go and get a uh you
should probably go get a new toaster
okay that's valid that's a pre that's a
reasonable my computer is broken i'll
buy a new computer right my toaster is
bro i want toast let's get a new toaster
but that's i said with all due respect
to the kids i said that's a little
simple don't you think i mean it might
be something i could fix and i wouldn't
have to buy a new toaster let's think
about like the system what is the where
does the toaster exist
in the world and they're all kind of
thinking and then and then somebody says
is the power on to the toaster that's a
great question i like that that's a yes
no question
i i don't think the power is on how
would i check to see if the power's on
and they said well plug something else
in
now we're going now we're getting
somewhere okay i plug in a lamp to the
same plug as the toaster lamp doesn't
turn on and they said okay did you blow
a fuse you know my parents say that
there's this fuse box maybe that's a
thing
i just wanted toast we're only five
minutes in and they're already thinking
about electricity and how it flows and
they're thinking about how it enters the
house and then i they say is the power
on at all
what a great question
no i don't have any lights on in the
whole house
and they're still trying to figure out
what the questions to ask and then one
little girl in the front row who'd been
real quiet
said do the neighbors have power
that's a programmer right there
i wanted toast and she's looking out the
window to see if the neighbor's lights
are on
and i and i said think about that i just
want bread that's hot
and you're checking to see if the
neighbors have power now at this point
they're kids so the whole thing goes off
the rails they want to know if there's
been an emp and aliens have taken over
you know and i just wanted toast but the
point is when you have a problem that is
simple like that you can either have a
simple answer buy a new
toaster which would not solve my toast
situation at all i would still have no
toast if they bought a new one but if
you think about the system in which it
exists
you're going to be able to do some
damage
so
early in career people they google for
stuff we see the memes they joke about
it on tick tock i'm on tech talk the
tick tock version for techies and they
always joke about oh yeah you know
stack overflow you can be a senior
engineer and make six figures on stack
overflow or whatever
and actually one of them
uh gave me a gift saying that i too
could be a senior engineer
let me see if i have my gift in my in my
bag here they actually gave me a a stack
overflow keyboard
it's got a copy button a paste button
and a stack overflow button
and that's how you become a senior
engineer at the company right there that
is simplistic thinking that will only
get you a job in tech or an interview in
tech and then you're going to get
overwhelmed in tech and you're going to
quit tech
we don't want to create people like that
so i was thinking about all the
different things that one would need to
make
to debug a website and just without
looking anything up without stack
overflowing anything i went and i made a
list of all the different things that i
would check and i realized i could make
a seven or eight page list and then i
thought about our famous american
president
abraham lincoln who said it's always dns
but on the left-hand side here i have a
whole list of things that it could be
did not google to get that list i didn't
even google with bing i just there's
just they just came out of my head
why do i know that stuff because it's
happened before because i've suffered
i've suffered and there's this one here
i don't know if you can see it in the
corner here
that you have to be aware that sometimes
it's never a certain thing
uh sherlock holmes
says it's never twins
now that's be like if you've ever seen
sherlock holmes whether it be a movie or
the book usually like a woman will kill
her husband and then they'll say well
but she has an alibi
she was on the other side of town
so there's two of them and they go wait
hang on how is that possible she killed
her husband but she was on the other
side of town and then watson says holmes
could it have been twins and he goes no
why not it's never twins
there's just stuff like that that
happens in tech that it's never going to
be and you're going to know those things
and you've had those interactions before
we go could it be that no it's never
it's never that
computers have a lot of layering issues
layering is hiding complexity from
yourself and others layering is also
really just lying
you're lying to yourself with software
you're hiding stuff
now this is what email looks like right
we've all sent an email before unless
you've worked on an smtp server a simple
mail transport protocol you've never
really seen what's behind that
i've spent my whole life never had to
write a simple mail transfer protocol or
a pop3 so i don't really know what's
behind email so i figured i'd look at it
that's what's behind email
it's name colon value name colon value
and then on line 10 there we see a
content type that's interesting where
have i seen stuff like that this is an
html post
named call and value
then i realize that the entire world is
just
name value pairs at scale
redis databases all of it's all a
lie everything's just a big hash table
in the cloud
why do i say that because it's true
so this is important for an early and
career person because when they start
plugging the neurons in and realizing
well that thing that i know is the same
thing as that thing that i know and then
you plug them in
you realize that maybe you already know
the thing
these two ideas are the same
on the right is a record player with
data that's encoded in a circle that
gets picked up by a head
on the left is a hard drive with data
encoded in a circle that gets picked up
by a head 150 years separate same
concept and it's still a wheel
isn't that interesting
then you can start composing things
putting things together and you can hide
information and
compose large systems that are
infinitely complex but then you can
still dig into them there's this really
great show on netflix have you ever seen
altered carbon
altered carbon is this great show and on
altered carbon this gentleman on the
right here
can can change bodies he can put his
brain inside different bodies and he
meets the guy on the left who's actually
an a.i
so he's an artificial intelligent and
he's he is the form of the poet edgar
allan poe
and the hotel he stays and it's called
the raven
and if you've ever seen altered carbon
you'll know that there's there's famous
people
playing the role and then there's that
guy who you don't know
he's a working actor
and i'm a big fan and if you saw altered
carbon you'd know that he was
amazing
he'd chewed it up he carried this show
carried it
so i always like to tweet the kind of
not famous people
and tell them hey you did a great job
because if i treat the famous person
they're never going to see it and they
get compliments all the time but the
working actor they never get it so i'm
going to just go and say hey and he had
like 4 000 followers you were amazing
you were awesome good for you and all
the best in your future success and he
tweets me back and i noticed that his
tweet has a geo-coded location he's in
portland
i live in portland
so if you know you gotta shoot your shot
my friends because you miss all the
shots that you don't take
so if i'm gonna have a bromance with
this man i gotta go right now while he's
in front of his phone and i said hey
i see that you're in portland yeah yeah
we moved to portland
[Music]
you want to get tacos
and we freaking got tacos and we hung
out and it was amazing and we went to
tacos and he shows up in a vest
and uh and like a an ascot it's like are
you european are you not european like i
don't know you know how they can tell
that you're an american from your
clothes
you know you can see you look at our
shoes and you're like guys from
america look at this a vest not a choice
i would make
and and like an ascot or like a like a
scarf very stylish so we do a podcast
and i bring my recorder and i interview
him about his acting process and it's
amazing and i'm like this is my new
buddy i'm going to be friends with this
guy so i go home
with my sd card
and i put it into the computer to get
the interview off
and there was an infinite
recursive directory of nothing
blank not even a space literally
nameless
folders that recursed infinitely
i
freaking felt it in my chest i was gonna
die what am i gonna do do i call him and
go hey remember that really amazing
dinner talk can we do that again um i'm
a computer person but i lost the file
right because he thinks i'm amazing
computer guy because i got like a blue
check on twitter right and he thinks i'm
the man and i'm going to tell him i lost
the file
oh my god so i go into explorer an
explorer says there's 300 megabytes
there and i'm like
but there's not there's only drawn
travolta going like this
so i start digging and digging and
digging and i realize that if i'm ever
going to be friends with this guy i'm
going to have to go and learn the file
allocation table format
for dos
so i take the but the bits off of the sd
card and make an array and i have this
300 meg array of zeros
and i start reading and reading and
reading and i learn
stuff about fat the file allocation
table that you shouldn't know like that
row of zeros should be zero zero two and
the date should not be nineteen eighty
and i start digging around in the bits
and i am not a low level debugger
but i
i i can't go on stage and talk about
driving stick shift if i don't actually
learn how to drive a stick shift
so this is the
stick shift version of rebuilding a file
system from scratch
so i manually rebuild the file
allocation table on the sd card and i
dig the files out and i find them and i
publish the interview
and he's still talking to me and we're
buddies and we like text each other so
that is very exciting to me
um because i could never have shown my
face the only choice would have been to
move to another city there was just no
way out of this
nothing in the computer is hidden from
you you can dig as far as you want
so i try to make sure that folks
understand that you may be working in
applications you may be doing text boxes
over data
but that sits on a file system that sits
on i o controls and all the way down
until there's a rock
that we put lightning in and we taught
it how to think
it's super important to understand that
stuff so then when you're old and you've
been in tech for a long time why are you
so good
it's because you've seen it before
that's the only reason
and the way that you get to be old in
tech is by not being
chased out of tech by jerks
there were so many opportunities where i
felt bad and i didn't belong and think
about how you must feel if you're
underrepresented person in tech
don't chase them out because if they get
in for 10 years then they maybe will
stay for 10 or 15 or 20 and they'll grow
more people my superpower having seen 30
plus years of tech for money and 40 if
you count not money is i've seen it
before that's it
that is the power one time i was
debugging for 13 hours on a raspberry pi
and i could not figure out why i
couldn't get this app to work
and i had these files on a raspberry pi
and i put one in a folder called good
and i put one in a folder called bad and
the only difference between the two
things was
that little space there if you can see
right up at the top there it says 2c and
there's a space
all of the zero d's
were stripped out of my file
all of the zero ds were missing why
anyone know any old people know what's
zero d and why it's missing
i spent 13 hours on this
say it again
sorry what
okay
my contemporary here
contemporary means we're the same age he
says carriage return
thank you for not being there when i
needed you
as a mentor
13 hours ago sir
turns out there's a setting treat files
without extensions as ascii i was
copying the file and it treated a binary
file as an ascii file and a 0d
as my fellow old person just said that
means carriage return so i go and i fix
the problem and i tell a young person at
work and they go that's amazing story
what's a carriage and where is it
returning to
there's people you ex experts in get
that don't know what a carriage return
is so i said well
let's talk about carriage
returns it's returning the carriage why
is it called a carriage because it
carries or transports the paper
and it goes
and you return the carriage and then you
line feed
and how does he know that because he's
seen it before
he didn't learn that in school and
remember it years later he's seen it
before this woman this bug will never
fool me again
so you know how they say fail fast fail
often
the way i know that is because i failed
a lot so what we can do is we can make a
space for early and career developers to
fail comfortably often so that they
might collect this stuff in their brains
and be more successful developers and
maybe even someday build a lego
typewriter
from scratch which i think would be
really exciting right
so i'm going to fast forward to the end
here's my homework for you all to think
about where what are your stories
collect your stories write them down
tell them to your mentees and your early
and career folks encourage them inspire
them do your stories humanize tech they
humanize you my stories are all about
how dumb i am you may have noticed that
and enable them to share their stories
and give them a spotlight we are so glad
that you're here at ndc thank you very
much
have a great show
[Music]